Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Annenizin, babanızın,
çocuğunuzun hayatı için
kaç para değer biçersiniz?
Çok çirkin, çok zor bir soru
öyle değil mi?
Peki en yakın arkadaşınızın hayatı
kaç para eder, diye sorsalar?
Buna ne cevap verirsiniz?
Büyük ihtimalle bırakın
bunlara cevap vermeyi,
bu soruları sormak bile
içinizi acıtır, canınızı yakar,
midenizi bulandırır.
Biliyorum çok zor
ama sizden rica ediyorum,
bir an için bir saniyenizi verin
ve size birazdan soracağım
sorunun sorulduğunu hayal edin.
Ne yapardınız? Nasıl bir tepki verirdiniz?
Yine çok sevdiğiniz, ailenizden
arkadaşınız gibi gördüğünüz
canı olan, nefes alan,
huyları, karakteri, ruhu olan,
hisleri, en önemlisi canı olan,
kediniz köpeğiniz atınız
ya da kuşunuz için bu soru sorulsa
ne yaparsınız?
Zor, değil mi?
Çok zor.
Ne yazık ki ülkemizdeki
yasal düzenlemeler yüzünden,
hayvanlar can değil mal olduğu için
bu soruyla karşı karşıya kalabilirsiniz.
Eşim ve ben bu soruyla
karşı karşıya kaldık ne yazık ki
ve zaten köpeklerimiz, yani arkadaşlarımız
Cango ve Pamuk öldürüldüğü zaman
hayatımızın her alanında yer açtığımız,
gözümüzden sakındığımız köpeklerimiz
öldürüldüğünde canımız çok yandı,
hâlâ çok yanıyor
ve her mahkemede, her duruşmada
biz bu acıyı bir daha yaşıyoruz.
Ama bize sorarsanız tüm bu mahkemeler,
bu duruşmalar, davalar boyunca
"En çok ne zaman canınız
yandı?" diye sorarsanız,
sanırım eşim de,
ben de aynı cevabı veririz:
Bize bu soru sorulduğu zaman.
Yani, "Cango ve Pamuk kaç para eder?"
diye sorulduğu zaman.
Bu soru sorulduğunda zaman durdu.
Her duruşmada ben eşimin
hemen arkasında otururum.
O duruşmada yine hemen
arkasındaki yerimde oturuyordum.
Bu soru soruldu.
Eşim döndü, bana baktı.
Kalbimiz, gözlerimiz, acımız,
öfkemiz, şaşkınlığımız bir oldu.
Hiçbir cevap veremedi tabii ki.
Ne cevap verebilirsiniz böyle bir şeye?
Hiçbir hayvan için,
sahipli ya da sahipsiz,
böyle bir sorunun cevabı olamaz.
Önüne döndü,
bu soruyu yönelten kişi zaten
bu sorunun ne kadar zor olduğunu,
kendisinin de sormakta ne kadar zorluk
çektiğini ama sistemin böyle olduğunu
ve sormak zorunda olduğunu
dile getiren kişi dedi ki,
"İsterseniz biraz düşünün.
Size biraz zaman vereyim,
sonra cevaplarsınız," dedi.
Ama bize istediğiniz kadar zaman verin,
istediğiniz kadar zaman, biz hiçbir
zaman bu sorunun cevabını veremeyiz
çünkü bu sorunun hesaplanacak,
matematiğini yapılacak bir yanı yok.
Bizim anılarımız, hatıralarımız
ve hayallerimiz vardı.
Cango ve Pamuk bizim için
paha biçilemez, her hayvan öyle.
Ama dedim ya, yasal düzenlemeler böyle.
Bilenleriniz vardır,
bilmeyenleriniz vardır.
Benim gibi hâlâ ve hep
kafası karışık olanlar vardır.
Müsaade ederseniz konuşmama
şu andaki mevcut durumu çok kısaca
özetleyerek devam etmek istiyorum.
Türkiye'de hayvan haklarına dair
iki tane temel yasal düzenleme var.
Birincisi, 5199 sayılı
Hayvanları Koruma Kanunu.
İkincisi de, Hayvanların Korunmasına
dair Uygulama Yönetmeliği.
Her ikisinde de yapılan
bütün kötü davranışlar;
muameleler, öldürmeler, tecavüzler
suç değil, kabahat
ve her ikisinde de bunun karşılığı
sadece idari para cezası.
Ama eğer hayvanınız sahipliyse,
yani bir karnesi varsa
işte o zaman şikayet etme hakkınız var.
Suç duyurusunda bulunabilirsiniz
ve belki bir ceza davası açılabilir.
Ama hatırlatmak istiyorum,
hayvanlarımız can değil mal olduğu için
bu ceza davasında da
yeri çok kolaylıkla doldurulabilecek,
mesela bir koltuk gibi, iskemle gibi,
zarar görmüş araba gibi
değerlendirilecek köpeğiniz.
Yani o yeri asla doldurulamayacak
hayvan dostlarınız,
zarar görmüş bir araba gibi, yani mala
zarar verilmiş gibi değerlendirilecek.
Çok acı, değil mi?
İşte bu yüzden hayvan
tecavüzcüleri, hayvan katilleri,
hayvanlara işkence edenler
için olan kanunlar
asla yeterli ve caydırıcı değildir
ve yine aynı nedenle,
her sene bu güzel ülkede
bizim yaşadığımız,
çocuklarımızın en güzel şekilde
yaşayacağını hayal ettiğimiz ülkede
on binlerce hayvan öldürülüyor,
tecavüze uğruyor,
işkence görüyorlar,
organları yerlerinden çıkartılıyor,
kuyrukları kesiliyor,
ses tellerini bile söküyorlar.
Canlarını alıyorlar
ve bunları yapanlar insanlar.
Bizim bunu anlayabilmemiz mümkün değil.
Eminim hiçbirinizin
anlayabilmesi mümkün değil.
Bizim bunu çocuğumuza da
anlatabilmemiz mümkün değil
ve biz zaten çocuğumuza
bunları anlatmak istemiyoruz.
Biz eşimle çocuğumuz doğduğundan beri
çabucak yürüsün, en hızlı o yürüsün,
işte en çabuk o konuşsun,
bir sürü iki dil üç dil
dört tane dil bilsin,
hani bugünün anne babaları
var ya, hiç öyle olmadık.
Biz hep dedik ki,
hayvan sevsin, doğa sevsin, insan sevsin.
Biz başka şeyler anlatmak istedik,
mesela ağaç ve yaprak niye yeşil?
Çiçekler rengarenk
ve o çiçeklerin renklerinin ismi ne?
Hayvanlar ahenkle yaşıyorlar ve çok
mutlular, biz bunları anlatmak istedik.
Eminim sizler de öyle.
Anlatacak şeyler çok farklı
ve çocuklara aslında çok da
anlatmaya gerek yok, onlar görüyorlar.
Dediğim gibi, bunu bizim anlayabilmemiz
ve anlatmamız çok zor.
Yaşanan birçok acı olaydan sonra,
kendi davamızı bir kenara
koyuyorum, o hepimizin davasıydı,
gördüğümüz destek için ne kadar
teşekkür etsek az sosyal medyada, basında.
Sosyal medya, basın, küçük açılan
kampanyalar, büyük yapılan kampanyalar;
hepsi çok çok çok kıymetli
ama aslında daha önemlisi var,
biz birileri olarak ne yapabiliriz?
Bizler ne yapabiliriz?
O kanun çıkmak zorunda, artık hayvanlar
mal değil can olarak kabul edilmeli.
O yasa çıkmalı, o düzenleme olmalı
ama o süreçte bizler ne yapmalıyız?
Hepimizin birilerinden bir şeyler
beklediği bir dönemdeyiz
ve ne demişler, "En tehlikelisi, dünyayı
birilerinin kurtarmasını beklemek."
O yüzden beklemeden biri
olarak bugün ben karşınızdayım.
Birinin annesi, birinin karısı,
birinin ablası
ama en önemlisi böylesine bir
acıyı yaşamış, zorluklarını bilen,
haksızlıklarını bilen
biri olarak karşınızdayım
ve size birtakım önerilerim,
tavsiyelerim, naçizane fikirlerim var.
Onları paylaşmak isterim.
Eğitim en önemli şey ve "Eğitim her şeyin
başı," lafıdır zaten hepimiz biliyoruz
ve hayatımızda herhâlde en
kıymet vermemiz gereken cümle.
Ailede eğitimle başlamak istiyorum.
Ben, eşim, bizim annelerimiz, babalarımız
hep hayvanlarla büyümüşler.
Evde kediler köpekler,
bahçede, sokakta baktıklarımız.
Karnımızda uyuyan kediler, biz
evden çıkarken uğurlayan köpekler.
Kız kardeşim ve ben mesela;
karnımız ağrıdığında
kedimiz karnımızda yatar,
başımız ağrıdığında koynumuzda uyur,
böyle bir evde büyüdük.
Eşim -- kayınpederim dermiş ki rahmetli
kayınpederim, oğlumun da isim babası,
95 yıllık ömrü boyunca hep demiş ki,
"Köpeğiniz olmadan geçen
her gün kayıp bir gündür."
ve tüm ömrünü de öyle yaşamış,
hep yanında en yakın
arkadaşları, köpekleri olmuş.
Ama herkes böyle yaşamayabilir,
ortamı böyle olmayabilir,
hayat şartları böyle olmayabilir,
tercihi böyle olmayabilir
ama çocuklarımıza hayvan sevgisi, yani
evdeki ve ailedeki o ilk eğitimi verirken
evimizde hayvan bakmak
ve beslemek zorunda değiliz.
Bunu çok farklı şekillerde yapabiliriz.
Mesela neler yapabiliriz;
avm'lere götürmektense çocuğumuzu,
barınaklara götürebiliriz,
hayvanat bahçesine, sirke götürmektense
barınaklara götürebiliriz
ve barınaklarda çocukların hayvanlarla bağ
kurmasına çok güzel bir yol açabiliriz.
Orada sevgiye ihtiyacı olan hayvanları
tanıyabilir, vakit geçirebilirler.
Çocuklarımızı mesela soğuk havalarda
dışarıdaki kedi ve köpekler için
kulübe yapmaya teşvik edebiliriz.
Onlara bir kulübe yapmanın,
ailece yapılacak
ne kadar keyifli güzel bir aktivite
olduğunu gösterebiliriz, yaşatabiliriz.
Evde artan sofrada yemeklerimiz oluyor,
onları mesela alıp sokaktaki, mahalledeki
ya da ormanda, barınaktaki
hayvanlara götürmenin
ne hoş ve güzel bir his verdiğini,
bize ne kadar kendimizi
iyi hissettirdiğini gösterebiliriz.
Tabii bunları sadece çocuğumuza
hayvan sevgisi vermek için
yılda bir kere, haftada bir kere değil;
hayatımızın akışı içinde, önce biz anne
babaların ve yaşam biçimimizde olmalı ki
çocuklarımızın da doğalı bu olmalı.
Hepimiz çocuklarımıza mesela
"Harçlıklarını biriktir,
paranın değerini bil," bunu
öğretmeye çalışıyoruz, öyle değil mi?
O zaman o harçlıklar biriktirildiğinde
bir oyuncakçıya koşmayalım da
mama alalım, yem alalım.
Onları kuşlarla, kedilerle,
köpeklerle paylaşalım.
Yapacağımız o kadar çok şey var ki
ve yine en basit görev aslında
hayvanlar konusunda anne babada
çünkü çocuklar dünyaya geldikleri zaman,
zaten doğanın, tabiatın
bir parçası olduklarını biliyorlar.
Hayvanları çok seviyorlar,
çiçekleri, ağaçları, böcekleri, arıları,
inekleri; hepsini çok seviyorlar.
En sevdikleri masalları düşünün,
okudukları kitapları,
izledikleri filmleri, çizgi filmleri,
oynayıp uyudukları hayvanları düşünün;
neredeyse hepsi hayvan.
Oyuncaklarının neredeyse hepsi hayvan.
Yani aslında anlatmanıza gerek yok,
onlar sizi taklit ediyorlar.
Anlatarak öğrenmiyorlar,
gördüklerini kopyalıyorlar.
O yüzden onlara bunları gösterebiliriz,
çok kolay, hiç zor değil.
İkincisi de eğitimde okul.
Okuldaki eğitim belki de
en önemlisi ve kıymetlisi
çünkü çocuğumuzu kendimizce
doğru değer yargılarıyla,
sevgiyle, saygıyla
yetiştirmeye çalışıyoruz.
Çocuklarımız en sağlıklı, en iyi
en güzel, en mutlu olsun,
en doğruyu bilsin istiyoruz.
Kim aksini isteyebilir ki?
Ama sonra bir yaşa geliyorlar,
onların elinden tutuyoruz,
taş bir binanın önüne götürüyoruz
ve diyoruz ki,
"İşte bu senin ikinci evin,
burası senin okulun.
Artık her gün buraya geleceksin.
Servis şoförü her sabah
seni evinden alacak götürecek,
akşam eve getirecek.
Onlarca yeni arkadaşın
olacak hiç tanımadığın,
ailesini bilmediğin, huyunu bilmediğin,
değer yargılarını bilmediğin.
Annenden babandan belki daha çok
göreceğin bir öğretmenin olacak.
Öğretmenlerin olacak.
Çok sevip hayran olduğun bir müdür
ya da belki de çok korktuğun bir müdürün."
Hademeler, sekreterler.
Yani artık sizin çocuğunuzun hayatında
kopyalayacağı, taklit edeceği
sayısız insan girmiştir.
Artık bizler aile olarak, çocuklarımızı
okulla birlikte yetiştiriyor olacağız
ve okulda öğrendikleri her şey,
onların geleceğinin adımları,
karakterlerinin mimarisi olacak.
Başta anlattığım o sevgi dolu aile tablosu
var ya yapabileceklerimizi anlattık,
dünyanın gerçekleri var.
Herkes böyle bir evde,
böyle bir yuvada büyümeyebilir.
Şartlar, hayat böyle olmayabilir.
Okula gittiklerinde, eğer
öyleyse hayatları, harika!
Bu artık onların hayatının
bir parçası ve devam ediyor
ama eğer değilse,
işte okul öyle düşünmeli.
Mesela o hayalini kurduğumuz kulübeyi
öğretmenler, müdürler yapmalı
okulun bahçesine
ya da okul gezileri barınaklara olmalı
ya da çocuklara derslerde anlatılmalı
harçlıklarıyla yapacakları güzel şeyler.
Ya da kantinde yemekhanede
artan yemekleri,
öğretmenlerimizle, arkadaşlarımızla
birlikte bizler bir kaba koymalıyız
ya da bir kap su bırakmalıyız.
Amerika'da ve Avrupa'da
okul kitaplarının içinde
hayvan sevgisi bir ders
olarak işleniyor, okunuyor.
Bizde niye olmasın?
Ödevlerde, hikâyelerde anlatılan
her şeyde hayvan ve doğa sevgisi,
onlara duymamız gereken
saygı anlatılabilir.
Çocuğumuzun yanına
kimin oturacağını bilmiyoruz.
Mesela o çocuk elinde yarım kalan
suyu ağacın köküne dökebilir
ya da başka bir çocuk çimlere basıp,
çiçeği koparıp, dalı kırıp,
kedinin kuyruğunu çekip
kahkahalar atabilir, bilmiyoruz.
Öğretmenler çocukların
okula kaçta gidip geldiğine,
ödevlerini nasıl yaptıklarına,
sınavdan ne notlar aldıklarına çok önem
veriyorlar ve etmek durumundalar
ama aynı çocukların
bahçede ne yaptıklarına,
hayvanlarla, ağaçlarla
nasıl bir ilişkileri olduğuna da
aynı özenle dikkat etmeleri gerekiyor,
etmemiz gerekiyor,
birbirimizin de çocukları için
ve üçüncüsü en önemlisi,
evde ailede eğitim, okulda eğitim,
peki evde ve okulda göremeyenler?
Hayatın ıska geçtiği, hayatın daha
zor bir sayfasıyla kitaba başlayanlar?
İşte o zaman toplum olarak,
devlet olarak, aile bireyi olarak
başta bahsettiğimiz birileri olarak
o insanlara sahip çıkmak zorundayız
çünkü zamanında kaçırdığımız,
dikkat edemediğimiz
ailede ve okulda bu hayvan,
doğa ve tabiat sevgisini görmeyenler
hepimiz için büyük bir tehlike ne yazık ki
ya da tehlike olma olasılığı çok fazla.
İşte bu noktada hepimizin birbirimizi
eğitmesi ve birlik olması gerekiyor.
Çocuk istismarına uğrayan
çocukların evlerinde,
%88'inin evinde,
hayvana karşı kötü muamelenin
olduğunu söyleyen adli tıp uzmanı,
değerli bilim insanı Sevil Atasoy'un
çok kıymetli bir makalesini okudum.
Konuşmamı bitirmeden o makaleden
birkaç gerçekle devam etmek istiyorum.
Çocuklara karşı, yaşlılara karşı
istismarda bulunanlar,
eşlerini dövenler,
şiddetin her türlüsüne eğilimi olan
insanların çocukluğunda ve geçmişinde
giderek artan ve çoğalarak devam eden
hayvanlara karşı
kötü muameleye rastlanmış.
Geçmişte yapılan araştırmalar
ve yaşananlar göstermiş ki,
bu insanların acımasızca yaptıkları
hislerle davranışlarının
hep geçmişinde hayvanlara
karşı kötü davranışlar varmış.
Seri katillerin neredeyse tamamında,
önce bu canavarca
hislerle gerçekleştirdiklerini
hayvanlar üzerinde uygulamışlar.
Psikiyatri alanında çalışanların
ve onlara bağlı meslek gruplarında
bir kişinin karakter bozukluğu ya da
kişilik bozukluğu olup olmadığını anlamada
hayvanlara karşı kötü muamele de çok
önemli bir bulgu olarak kabul ediliyormuş
ve daha birçok şey var
ve elbette ki biz,
hayvanlara karşı kötü davranan
çocukların ileride bir katil
ya da bir tecavüzcü olacağını söyleyemeyiz
ama hangi çocukların
ne yapabileceğini de asla bilemeyiz.
O yüzden toplum olarak bu
erken işaretleri çok doğru okumalıyız.
Çok dikkat etmeliyiz
çünkü bugün o can değil
mal olarak gördükleri
kedilere, köpeklere,
kuşlara, hayvanlara;
bunlara acımasızca yapabilenler,
yarın bizim çocuklarımıza,
annelerimize, eşlerimize, sevdiklerimize,
tanımadığımız, tanıdığımız insanlara
bunları yapabilecek insanlar.
Ne yazık ki bunun gerçeğini
artık anlamamız,
bunu kabul etmemiz gerekiyor.
Çok dikkatli olmamız gerekiyor
ve bu insanların
gerekli cezaları alması için
hiç durmadan çalışmaya
devam etmemiz gerekiyor.
Tekrar söylüyorum,
hepimizin birilerinden bir şey
beklediği bu dünyada
o birileri biz olalım
çünkü çocuklarımızın
bizden çok daha güzel,
çok daha güvenli ve vicdan dolu bir
dünyada yaşaması bizim elimizde.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum, çok sağ olun.
(Alkış)